36 palombes président de la
confédération des commerçants de france
bonsoir francis palombes merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france les gilet
jaune de nouveau dans la rue est ce que
vous redoutez ce retour des
manifestations tous les samedis bien
évidemment vadam parce que ça fait
bientôt deux ans que nous sommes sous le
coup des manifestations qui se sont
succédé pour en arriver bien sûr au co
vide avec toutes les conséquences les
monsieur dallas parler pour les
discothèques et nous nous associons
totalement à l'action des discothèques
nous en parlons actuellement avec notre
ministre des tpe pme
monsieur brisé alain griset des parties
peremans attentif aux très petites
entreprises
donc c'est vrai que nous sommes inquiets
aujourd'hui est que l'on doit constater
ce qui est ce qui est et ce qui est bien
et bien une meilleure maîtrise une
meilleure organisation une plus grande
efficacité des forces de police que l'on
doit saluer et je pense pouvoir apporter
une certaine satisfaction sans que ce
soit parfait pour nous il ne faut pas de
manifestation pour que les commerçants
puissent travailler et ce n'est pas
toujours le cas et ça n'a pas toujours
été le cas
mais il faut reconnaître que le nouveau
ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin à apporter un grand plus
dévots aujourd'hui j'ai interrogé des
commerçants cet après midi qui est et
place des ternes
il bondit bon on a fait moins de
chiffres bien évidemment quand les
manifestants sont là mais il n'y a pas
eu de casse il n'y a pas eu de
débordement il n'y a pas eu de défilé
donc au niveau sécurité ça s'est
beaucoup amélioré et ça on peut s'en
féliciter
mais il ya un point sur lequel je
voudrais attirer l'attention des
pouvoirs publics des médias c'est que
jusqu'à présent quand il ya eu des
manifestations successives les
commerçants qui se trouvait sur le
parcours
demande des manifestations et bien je
peux vous dire que la plupart n'ont pas
été dédommagés des dégâts qu'ils ont
subi bon il ya eu des assurances qui
sont intervenus pas toujours donc par
exemple il faut à l'avenir que les
assurances quand il y a des gars
abolisse toute notion de franchise et
nous allons continuer à travailler avec
monsieur le ministre
alain crise et des pme tpe sur ces
questions donc inquiet oui si tous les
samedis à nouveau se dérouleront des
manifestations pour le commerce ça va
devenir intolérable
on sort d'un kobe 19,1 déconfinement
difficile des filles d'affaires en
baisse si en plus ça continue tous les
samedis qui est le meilleur jour de la
semaine à perdre du chiffre d'affaires
ça ne pourra plus durer et il faudra que
l'état continue à accentuer l'aide aux
très petites entreprises les plus
affectées et plus fluide et si vous
voulez bien compte tenu que monsieur
morte quand dale a parlé tout à l'heure
hors antenne vous donne toute
autorisation pour lui donner mon numéro
de portable
hassen que je m'entretienne allait lui
pour soutenir cette catégorie socio
professionnelle très très touche on va
transmettre françois pas longue vie
néanmoins les manifestants ont le droit
de manifester vous l'avez dit ça s'est
plutôt bien passé il ya eu quelques
tensions vous mettez ça sur le crédit de
la nouvelle doctrine est victime hier
par jal darmanin au moins d'usagers de
grenades de désencerclement fin des
grenades - moins violente a priori ou
sur l'attitude tout simplement des
manifestants écoutez ya les deux d'abord
vous avez pu constater comme moins que
ce ne sont plus forcément les mêmes
manifestants d'abord il ya moins la
symbolique des gilet jaune en tant que
gilet jaune
mais surtout c'est vrai que c'était des
manifestants aient le droit à manifester
dans une démocratie comme nous le
représentant en france doit être
toujours bien évidemment préservé mais
très encadrée
donc là je pense que
la méthode en mallié on va appeler ça
comme ça la méthode darmanin a semblé
porter du ministre dans ma même pardon c
était un peu familier et bien a commencé
à porter ses fruits c'était moins
violent c'était ce n'était pas dans
l'agressivité totale sur le plan de
l'exercice police manifestants s'étaient
beaucoup mieux et je voulais dit tout à
l'heure d'ailleurs pour avoir interrogé
des commerçants par contre en province
beaucoup de villes n'ont pas été
forcément touchés n'ont pas eu de retour
de manifestations dans leurs virées pull
l'analyser en appelant des commerçants
oui apparemment ça s'est plutôt bien
passé en provence également il y avait
pourtant on l'a vu sur les images a
encore cette présence de casseurs les
policiers ont fait beaucoup
d'interpellations en amont on l'a vu
aussi v d exfiltration qu'on connaît de
la part des fameux policiers en civil
pour enlever de la foule les éléments
perturbateurs ça vous l'avez constaté
vous l'avez entendu de la part des
commerçants
oui absolument je vous dit tout à
l'heure un commerçant m'a dit ça s'est
beaucoup mieux passé que d'habitude
c'était beaucoup moins de temps tu vu et
ça il faut le reconnaître comme je
l'étais en début d'interview ce qui est
bien bien ce qui est pas bien et pas
bien il faut le dire donc plutôt une
satisfaction que la manifestation a eu
lieu mais elle s'est passée relativement
pacifiquement mais partons ce qu'a dit
le maire du xviie que je connais bien
monsieur boulard est important les
champs elysées ont été internés à
manifestations mais il faut que
l'essence de police eux étudient encore
plus profondément tous les secteurs de
paris parce que paris ce ne sont pas que
les champs-elysées la place des ternes
les halles où la rue de rivoli c'est un
ensemble d'arrondissement où il y a
beaucoup de commerçants et il faut que
ça soit bien répartie de mieux en mieux
répartie pour également protéger au
mieux les commerçants qui sont situées
sur le parcours des manifestations et
lmd réalisation des commerçants c'est
très important que je me réveille
merci beaucoup françois palombes merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos questions
francis palombes pardon merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur rt
france